I have diarrhea just moans it's like my
body's rigid these are allegedly the
spiciest instant noodle in Malaysia I
can do spice very well I've been clean
eating for over a week I've actually
been vegan for over a week now so my
body probably isn't gonna be used to
processing literally any of this
anything in this I'm from Louisiana so I
can't like handle spice but like extreme
spice is kind of like a different thing
it's gonna be a sad day for mine but you
know I like spicy so I'm gonna be the
one embarrassing myself today let's do
it this is not like any ramen I've had
this is like concentrated evil drip drip
baby I'm looking forward to this since
yesterday and iron stomach
all right these are good actually I feel
like I'm getting competitive now and I'm
like now I can finish it it reminds me a
little bit of like barbecue Oh looks
like my body's rigid yeah okay it is
incredibly spicy like I could feel it my
like nose is running I'll finish the
whole thing I might die but it'll be
worth it I'm good okay that's cool I
feel like I'm gonna make a mess myself
here I feel like this is gonna this is
gonna hurt me later buddy oh my ears
hurt like in my ears
all right yeah my whole body's kind of
getting numb it was like actually pain
I've never really felt this before
thank you so much cover my mouth like I
don't think I felt my tongue feel like
actual like stabs of pain oh my god yeah
I feel like I'm freaking out right now
I'm in pain
this is handsome it's incredibly painful
yeah I feel like my whole body's just
like vibrating yeah just what you wanted
I'm having a good time are you not
entertained my lips feel like there's to
me
I mean if you don't love yourself and
you can have this shirt you know knock
yourself out hey myself I'm having like
an out-of-body experience here you're
going through them oh my gosh
plugging like handles spice oh my god
this is going on the internet bugging
like handles spice bugging like handle
spice but I'm not like I feel like my
hands are look there's like or like cold
so I'm gonna be the one embarrassing
myself today huh
I wouldn't suggest this to the average
person know if you don't like spicy
stuff like you might find yourself
actually died I'm really impressed with
my recovery time your recovery
yeah I'm fine kinda like it's spicy very
good product congratulations hmm nothing
else to say there there are two kind of
people in this world right
you